governor sysolak announcing new steps
being taken as covet 19 numbers continue
to increase across our state
he wrapped up a news conference just a
short while ago good afternoon and thank
you for joining us at 4 i'm kirsten
joyce
and i'm christian casadez the i-team's
vanessa murphy was there during today's
announcement
she joins us live now in studio vanessa
good afternoon
governor steve siselek says the delta
variant is spreading like wildfire in
nevada the state reports a covid19 test
positivity rate of nearly 17 percent in
clark county
it's considered a problem if it's over 5
percent
hospitals report overcrowding and
staffing shortages but governor siselek
says
he is not planning another shutdown or
any capacity limits
he points to other steps he's taking
like a mass mandate
and three possibilities which are
currently being examined and considered
one a vaccine requirement at public
colleges and universities
to a vaccine requirement for the health
care workforce
and those working with vulnerable
populations like those in the homeless
community
and three he says he's also asked his
medical advisors to look at how to make
large gatherings safer governor siselek
says he's exploring these measures but
he is pleading with nevadans to get
vaccinated
almost every covet 19 death that we have
seen since january
of 2021 has been in the case of an
individual who is not fully vaccinated
again almost every death we have seen
since january of 2021 is in individuals
who have not
been fully vaccinated right now the
state is reporting that
46 48 of nevadans who are eligible for
the vaccine meaning they're ages 12 and
older
have received it and we've heard about
vaccine
passports for example in new york city
governor siselek today saying he doesn't
want to go
in that direction